I remember when I was doing Saving
Private Ryan there was a scene between a
couple other guys and Spielberg moved on
and we were he was marching off to the
next kind of little place he was going
to shoot and I said Steven you know
don't you think we should have done a
couple more takes of that thing you know
because it what hadn't been great he
turned on a dime and he said I could
spend another hour on that scene and
perhaps make it 10 better or I could go
do another great shot I'm gonna do the
shot Clint Eastwood is notorious for
always going with the first take what
was that experience like as an actor on
the set of Invictus I tested that theory
on day day one of shooting
we did the first take
it went pretty well but Clint says cut
print check the gate which means you
know we're done here we're going to move
on and I said oh hey boss you know maybe
you think we get one more and you just
turn and he goes why you want to waste
everybody's time all right okay we're
done all right good let's let's move on
so uh so I'm glad I put all that work in
because I really don't think I got more
than one take ever